in this video we'll talk about urinary
tract infection
urinary tract infection is the second
most common infection in the whole world
women are more susceptible
to develop uti compared to men
this is probably due to the anatomy
of the female
1 out of 10 male could get uti whereas 8
out of 10 females can get a uti
infection
so females has smaller distance between
the anal opening and the urethral
opening whereas in male the distance is
way more that means the chances of
getting contaminated by the fecal
matter associated bacteria is way more
and probably that is the reason why
females get more often
affected
now also
this urinary tract infection is kind of
dependent with hygiene and generally the
distribution is somewhat like this where
the developing countries are at higher
risk of developing uh the urinary tract
infection due to obvious reason reasons
like
hygiene and many other factors
so let's talk about the symptoms of uti
it involves pain in the lower abdomen
pain during urination dysuria
it involves cloudy urine
sometimes there are bad odors in the
urine there could be frequent urination
and
sometimes there could be fever and
chills as well
common causes of uti involves bacteria
because most of the cases uti are
bacteria borne disease
so there are many bacteria which can
cause uti majority of these bacteria are
gram negative bacteria especially
uropathogenic esterasia coli which
comprises 75 percent of them klebsiella
proteus mirabilis etc
there are many gram-positive bacteria as
well which can cause uti such as
staphylococcus
there could be enterococcus there could
be streptococcus all of these are
associated with urinary tract infection
very few cases of urinary tract
infections are non-bacterial maybe some
kind of fungus can cause also uti
now the most common one is uropathogenic
e coli and uropathogenic e coli express
multitude of virulence factors on them
which can break the
mucosal barrier and can invade in our
bladder and that's how this can lead to
cystic cystisis
and in a moment we would look at the
pathogenesis
the next one is staphylococcus
saprophyticus this is also a very common
bacteria which is uh form which is the
cause of cystisis in women women
probably it is related with
with the occurrence of natural flora in
the woman's vagina
and also it could be acquired with the
infection
with the catheter actually
now
the urinary tract infection
most commonly affect
the lower part of the urinary tract that
means bladder urethra etc so initially
it is urethritis when the urethra is
inflamed then it would be cystis when
the bladder is inflamed eventually
infection can spread up till the kidney
and then it would be known as
upper urinary tract infection it is less
frequent compared to a lower urinary
tract infection but in this situation
this is termed as acute nephritis a
pyelonephritis sorry
so there are different stages of uti
first stage is known as colonization
where bacteria forms small colony near
the urethra and starts its innovation
then there is europe helium penetration
where it really invades the euro
epithelium and kind of infects the
bladder and it kind of replicates their
increase in number possibly they can
also form biofilms
then they ascend
through the ureter and moves toward the
kidney where they can cause
pyelonephritis which is an acute
infection in the kidney ultimately there
could be kidney injury in long term if
untreated
the risk factor of urinary tract
infection involves using contaminated
public toilets
multiple sex partners
usage of catheter after surgery like in
especially if the catheters are
contaminated there would be high chance
that
there would be bacteria invading your
urogenital system
ultimately hormonal imbalance especially
during pregnancy can also lead to or
also increase the risk factor of
developing a urinary tract infection but
urinary tract infection is quite
treatable it's a bacterial infection so
obviously plethora of antibiotics can be
used a three to five day course of
antibiotic can heal the infection
in rare occasions when the situation is
untreated for a long time where
complications are more in that case
hospitalization might be required but i
hope this video was informative enough
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up
get all the notes and flash cards
associated with this video in my
facebook channel links are in the
description in the facebook channel you
could get many other flash cards which
are dynamic in nature highly interactive
would help would be helpful for your
preparation
don't forget to like share and subscribe
support my channel with super likes or
beam upi or patreon my courses are also
present in academy which is india's
biggest online online learning platform
feel free to take the course using my
code ap 10 you can get a 10 percentage